it would be a watershed moment according
to the report it could already be a
watershed moment this year might be the
first to see a drop in fossil fuels used
to generate electricity the first
outside of pandemic or recession this is
the grounds for optimism you can see
wind and solar now represent 12 of total
electricity production extend that
forward according to the think tank
Ember and you'll get less fossil fuels
in the Energy Mix worldwide and that
trajectory is based on what's been
happening in solar wind all around the
world you can see some countries moving
at a quicker Pace Oceana Europe as
regions doing better but everyone more
or less on the same Journey
last year 80 of the rise in electricity
demand globally was met with winds and
sober alone so every year has been going
on when and so have been forming our
higher and higher amount of the the
electricity that we we use incrementally
and now that's taking us towards the
Tipping Point where all of
um electricity demand grows globally is
met with clean power
so job done well no even if it is a
Tipping Point fossil fuel needs to
decline lots and needs to decline fast
clear power has been rising as a
proportion of our mix but because our
total electricity demand has also been
rising it means that fossil fuel
emissions are still going up there may
be a smaller slice of the pipe but the
pie is growing bigger so they're still
higher than ever and much of that is
because of our use of coal the most
polluting fossil fuel now there is good
news here around the world coal plants
have been shutting you see them closing
down below compared to opening above
that is a negative Trend that's the rest
of the world excluding one country and
that country is China and China leaves
the world in renewable energy but it
also leaves the world in koi you can see
how many more plants it's been opening
compared to how many it's been shutting
that obviously is not ideal that makes a
massive difference for those projections
we were talking about at the start and
whether the world really will made them
and across the board for all sorts of
important measures we are behind coal
needs to go down electricity needs to go
up gas needs to go down wind and solar
need to go up massively and every one of
those you can see these projections we
are a long way behind the pathway to
note zero there is a huge amount to do